Ukraine is still fighting for bakmut but
that fight is looking ever more
desperate
commanders here say Russia is now
sending its most prepared troops to the
front having sacrificed conscripts for
months and that increasing the
capabilities of their own Frontline
defenses has become quote problematic
the head of Russia's Wagner mercenary
group has warned them to get out while
they still have one road left to use
they are trying to beg the Ukrainian
Army to leave Bak moot so he would stop
defending the city they hope to get the
city without big losses but they've lost
so many people the catastrophe for the
Wagner group and the Russian army is
inevitable
Wagner's founder says he's with his
troops near bakmut and he had his own
Grim message for his Ukrainian opponents
we are sending another shipment of
Ukrainian Army Fighters home and they
fought bravely and perished that's why
this latest track will take them back to
their motherland
pregosian is publicly criticized
Russia's defense minister Sergey shoigu
for the many failures of the military
campaign so far perhaps no coincidence
then with the capture of bakmut
seemingly in sight he too should be in
eastern Ukraine yeah
in Western La Viv Ukraine's president
was meeting the president of the
European Parliament Roberto metzola
called for Speedy talks on Ukraine's EU
membership investigations into an
accountability for alleged Russian war
crimes and further Military Support
the Ukraine but it is clear that war is
needed if we want to have a safe Europe
we need to have a safe Ukraine there's
no safety to be found in bakmut a town
of more than 70 000 people has been
reduced to this about 3 000 are
estimated to remain among them hanadi
and Natalya Scavenging for what they can
to survive
because
there are problems with food Natalia
says humanitarian Aid is given to us
only once a month there's no electricity
no water no gas
we burn wood says hanadi at least it's
warmer
if Russia does soon Prevail in bakmut
after six months of attrition there's
little left to claim as a prize Natalia
says she can only pray that whoever does
remain here Will Survive
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera